プレって知った
お前
前紙コップでピラミッドつってわかるか
ないのそうでしょ3コップはお飲み物を飲むものなので僕はそういうので遊ばないの
ですデザインやっぱ作った人見た事はありますそれはもう全然ある
でもや紙コップは売ってる人をつけるものが三国は
ピラミッドを作るものです人は紙コップを見るとついつい
重ねてピラミッドつけてしまいたくなる話もかつて紙コップを大量にかい去年だけで3
つを作ったとき
まずはぁ
ものすごい満足感に襲われそこから3日夜寝れなかったそれぐらいそれぐらい
やっぱものを積み重ねて高いものを作るいいじゃないんだってそれを紙コップである
ならまだわかるんですけども
ブーブレを釣ってキャパティピラミッド作っ
それを見てみたいすごい満足感が得られるんじゃないかと思って今日は業者に頼んだ
最大の大スターがヶ月プライバケツで巨大なピラミッドを作ってみようと思います早速
やっていきましょう
これは早速作っていきましょう数えたところお台場結果21戸あったんで
6個54321っていう感じでピントを作っていきますよし行くぞ
はい
ああああああ
すごいはい
晴くん火力だなぁ
まず1番目つけていきます
スーパー
マジで重いんだよね動いてこれ
[音楽]
諌めてきましたどうだ
でまだよくわかんない値段でいきます
報道どうもーにで確かにで待ってこれ
大丈夫ですかえっ
ています
んか
だぜねー
[音楽]
2ぱるかなぜ疑似スーツを着ると普通の人の発売疲れるんだ
ハイ3打目終了しましたこれの3倍の長さになると思う
いやで腕船や梅雨結構はにてこれか
山でいきますやばい
の三段目で俺を覚えた
はいと言うけど3段目ができましたもう俺は戦争を私の船長を抜いておりますそれず4
ダメいきましょう
待ってくれもう無理な気がするしたな
ん
やばい高いあまり動いよだったり高いですか
ますできました大谷ばもうやばい室もう届かないすごくじゃあもう
ナンバー本当になるけどちょっと久しぶりに
ます
俺的休みたいなとで5段目ですもうこっからだったよく届くのかな
あげたら意外とイケたいきますよ
コントローラーで並べてみてください
持っています
ん
はい
la bella なくぽつ荷物からだとこれが限界なちょっと脚立持って行ってるん
で脚立使えます
わし
できました俺全然か行かねえマンアート1個が非常に難しい
もう脚立を使っても1個が届かない感じだったんで
どうしよういちかばちかだやってみるきゃねー
4日
[音楽]
ファイティングでなんと1個でいます
ええええええ
葉加瀬者
不安とかのシェできるだすげーなー
柄ファー
いいいいいい
ん
だろえっ
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ